so jetzt aber vor lauter merkel bei tram
theater bitte nicht das eigentliche welt
events der woche vergessen seehofer bei
putin gestern in moskau trafen sich mal
wieder der egomanische alleinherrscher
und der russische präsident perfekt
getimt perfekte teilen vom hort damit
die kanzlerin in washington bloß nicht
zu viel aufmerksamkeit kriegt seehofer
hatte sogar versuchen uns jetzt kein
witz vor merkel einen termin bei
sonnenschein zu kriegen machen die
bayern jetzt also endgültig ihre eigene
außenpolitik wir schauen mal ganz kurz
nach münchen zu dr matthias matschke
staatssekretär in der bayerischen
staatskanzlei
herr matschie ist das nicht ein affront
gegen die kanzlerin was sie da machen
aber unser credo ist heißt du kannst die
außenpolitik auf dauer nicht den
amateuren in berlin überlassen
oder wie wir bayern sagen dort müssen so
fachgerechte nehmen hat er sich ja kein
staatsstreich das läuft jetzt alles ganz
offiziell eingeweihten
königlich-bayerischen augen ministerium
hier aber die eu versucht eine
einigermaßen einheitliche russland
politik auf die reihe zu kriegen
da kann doch ihr herr seehofer nicht
einfach sein eigenes ding machen wenn
der ministerpräsident von brandenburg
kann auch kein fragen des abkommens
china abschließen
also da vergleich uns jetzt aber
wirklich glauben mit brandenburg ist ja
einfach nur ein bundesland bayern ist
ein land im übrigen weiß auf der herr
fuchs die bayerisch tschechischen
beziehungen fertig ist nicht für das im
vergangenen jahr die bayerischen exporte
nach russland um vier prozent zugenommen
haben während die übrigen exporte der
deutschen bundesländer und der
bundesrepublik insgesamt nach russland
um 48 prozent zurückgegangen sind
glückwunsch konnte nachfrage vielleicht
irre ich mich aber hatten wir nicht
sanktionen gegen russland feiern und
danach die a20 längst nicht feiern
wirklich alster genannte heutige franz
obermeier wer erster bayerischer
außenminister wird
während erster bayerischer außenminister
gut dass sie fragt wer glaubte ich sagte
nur er ist wieder da der freiherr der
stärkung der qualität seiner ganzen
pracht kommt jetzt mich wirklich der
sprechende copy form ist wieder am start
seit letzter woche ist außenpolitischer
berater der schritt keine position an
sondern er will seiner familie helfen
seine csu von wenn man an bescheidenen
beitrag dazu leisten kann
für diese familie dann gerne
damit ist alles so schön so reich wie
ich sagt er dass der lichten richtig los
für die familie nächste rausfliegt gute
idee nordkorea und eröffnet
zusammengekommen um die erste bayerische
protestiert gang ein tränchen matthias
matschke fehler als dankeschön
[Applaus]